this week on brian ross investigates the
first sons donald trump's sons and
daughter under investigation and now we
learn so is joe biden's son now more
than a year later it turns out the
laptop and at least some of its contents
are in fact real the children of
presidents have long been the subjects
of public scrutiny and oftentimes public
score
we'll get the latest on the politics of
investigating the first family's
children prize-winning investigative
journalist david k johnston
plus a former top cia operative on the
latest from ukraine and the
miscalculations in folly of russian
president putin
it's pretty clear that vladimir putin
has wildly miscalculated you know first
resolve of the west
second resolve of ukrainians
but third the performance of this
military and this week's winners and
losers in the media see if you agree
with the choices made by the editors of
mediaite why can't you condemn this as
an invasion
but
let's
don't be naive
from the studios of the law and crime
trial nepal in new york city's herald
square this is brian ross investigates
and good evening and thank you for
joining us and welcome to our friends on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined by
my colleague rhonda schwartz and rhonda
we begin with the first sons we've been
hearing for years about the
investigations involving the grown
children of donald trump but now the new
york times is reporting a serious
federal investigation of president
biden's son hunter
that's right brian the case was
initially dismissed during the last
presidential campaign season as
unfounded and some reports were actually
blocked from social media
the post claimed that the emails were
found on a laptop computer that was
brought to a repair shop in delaware in
the spring of 2019
and a shop employee
saw the emails
and then was worried about getting in
trouble or getting in danger and he made
copies of them
there's a lot about this story that does
not add up feel like a repeat from last
cycle it's the you know but her emails
again and it's kind of ridiculous then
and now the goal of these incidents
appears to be the same to cast a cloud
over the front runner in the closing
weeks of the campaign using a drip drip
drip of emails that create the era of
scandal even though republican-led
congressional investigations have never
uncovered any evidence of wrongdoing
this is a classic example of the
right-wing media machine a tip from
bannon and a hard drive dump from rudy
led a former producer for sean hannity
show to write a story for the new york
post that gets splashed on the front
page
the new york times has authenticated
emails that appear to have come from a
laptop abandoned by hunter biden in
delaware
the president previously said that the
new york post story about this was a
bunch of garbage and that it was a
russian plant does he stand by that
assessment i've appointed the department
of justice and also to hunter biden's
representatives he doesn't work in the
government
and to get a better understanding of
what's happening here we're joined by
pulitzer prize-winning investigative
reporter david k johnson who's written a
number of books about the trump family's
problems and issues now david as you
look at what's happened with this report
about hunter biden he's under serious
investigation according to the new york
times
yes and the biden administration has
left the trump appointed u.s attorney in
delaware who is in charge of this in his
post specifically
uh so that no one can accuse them of
interfering in what's going on now this
investigation it turns out dates all the
way back to 2019
it could involve the foreign agents
registration act
and more than a million dollars of
income taxes that
hunter biden should have paid and didn't
he has since paid them which complicates
bringing a federal tax charge
but the
biden white house is letting this case
proceed
under the direction of a trump appointee
is it likely that president biden's son
could be indicted before president
trump's grown children
yeah i i think at this point brian that
is a distinct possibility
uh on the other hand there's a problem
the justice department has with the case
there's no question that hunter biden
a self-described drug addict uh his
behavior is smarmy uh as has been the
pres the behavior of
uh
sons and brothers of presidents all the
way back to bushrod washington the first
president's son
but they have to prove criminal intent
and
the new york times's most recent story
very carefully walks through this and
shows that well he took steps to avoid
coming into the foreign agents
registration act and indicated he
wouldn't do this or that
there's doesn't appear to be anything at
least from the reporting in the new york
times where i used to work
that shows criminal intent just
smarminess and thoughtlessness indeed
david a question for you from ronda
schwartz rhonda
and at the same time the trump
investigation seems to have hit a
roadblock in the manhattan district
attorney's office is that investigation
just stalled or is that one dead
well
the it appears that alvin bragg the
newly elected district attorney in
manhattan has killed that investigation
he says it's going forward but evidently
there are no more witnesses being called
before the grand jury and the two lead
prosecutors one of whom is the literally
the expert on rico statutes resigned on
principle
now the state attorney general of new
york leticia james has only civil
authority inherently and she is pursuing
a civil case against trump
i
think it would be incumbent on alvin
bragg if he sees a problem in this case
to
give leticia james as the law provides
his criminal authority to investigate
and it's one of the things i've noticed
about this from the reporting on it it
appears that
alvin bragg was concerned that trump
lied to banks by inflating the value of
assets
if the banks didn't lose any money i can
see the difficulty in making a case like
that ronda
on the other hand you know he told tax
authorities this piece of property is
worth 1.3 million
this is his golf course in westchester
as both brian and i reported at the time
and then on a federal forum year after
year he says it's worth more than 50
million and he publicly says more than a
hundred million and there are a number
of other buildings where he did this so
i'm frankly very surprised that alvin
bragg
has turned out to you know apparently
have a jellyfish's spine
david as you know just before the
election uh the stories in the new york
post essentially were kept off social
media they were blocked was that a
mistake looking back at what we now know
yeah i think we need to allow much more
robust debate even though lots of things
on social media are nonsense and we know
that there's a great deal of russian
disinformation out there and i i i don't
have any examples but i'm sure that
there's also um
iranian
north korean
uh uh and various other governments
misinformation out there
the reporting in the new york times
which the right has said oh you know you
had a headline about it oh they they
finally admit something i just went back
and reread it it's actually a model of
how to deal with
uncertain facts particularly an
environment where we know the russians
have planted information it's actually
was quite thorough as is the current
story very nuanced
uh and
frankly you could use it as a model in
journalism school and i'm not a
journalism school product but
uses a model in journalism school to
teach here is how to report neutrally
and in depth when you don't know all the
facts all right david k johnson pulitzer
prize winning investigative reporter as
always thank you so much for being with
us here tonight
thank you brian and rhonda up next we'll
talk with the former top c.i.a official
what's coming next from vladimir putin
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live lawn
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
we turn now to the world's dismay of
what's happening in ukraine with some
intelligence analysts suggesting
vladimir putin could be prepared to
dangly escalate a limited war into a
world war
to get a better understanding of what's
happening we're joined now by mark
polymeropoulos who for 25 years served
in the cia retired as a senior
intelligence officer he's now a
non-resident fellow at the atlantic
council and author of the new book
clarity and crisis lessons learned at
the cia mark thanks so much for joining
us you know all about russia what's
going on you think based on what you
know about their operations well first
of all it's it's great to be here and
and what an extraordinary time i mean i
don't think any of us really predicted a
actual a land war in europe um but it's
pretty clear that that vladimir putin
has wildly miscalculated you know first
resolve of the west um second resolve of
ukrainians uh but third the performance
of this military which has been
absolutely atrocious so there's there's
really there's a lot to unpack here but
i'll tell you this you know on your
bingo card you know several months ago
you didn't have a land war in europe
on there and so you know pretty pretty
incredible developments that really are
affecting the world
given the miscalculation of vladimir
putin what's his next step they talk
about he could escalate to actual
chemical or limited nuclear attacks
sure so you know i think there is some
concern on that um but you know at some
point you know the the west has to show
continued resolve and not really be
paralyzed by this kind of this wmd
blackmail um i i would hope that there's
private messages being sent you know
today through military to military
channels that any introduction of wmd
inside ukraine will in fact uh cause a
response from nato and i think one of
the reasons why as well is the european
public is not going to sit by a and and
you know simply allow this to happen um
you know i don't know if a public
statement uh you know from from
president biden or the administration is
required that might box in putin too
much but clearly telling him behind the
scenes that this is a red line and we're
using that famous term red line um but
this would be unacceptable as bad as the
atrocities are now uh you know the the
idea of chemical or you know god forbid
nuclear weapons um being used uh you
know that that cannot be allowed to
stand and i think we have this we have
to really set that you know firmly in
motion it should be done behind the
scenes
uh the us and our nato allies are moving
lots of ammunition and weapon systems uh
into ukraine uh you know all about how
that works uh how does it work and what
happens if russia tries to attack those
supply lines or the depots where the new
equipment is being stored
well brian you know first and foremost
and this is in
the dna of frankly the intelligence
community the cia um in the special
operations community i mean you know
when you look at you know european
special operations command what's called
sakura for 70 years it's been waiting
for this moment to resist kind of a
russian invasion in europe so we do have
the ability um you know logistically to
push you know weapons uh uh across
international boundaries and and you
know for it not to be seen i think you
raise a really interesting point will
russia you know take that step and try
to interdict some of these um
again it depends if it's on the
ukrainian side of the border or perhaps
in poland or other places um but but i
think we you know you know the russians
have threatened to hit these these
convoys we have to keep pushing uh them
across and and again if if pot you know
if if required it goes more from covert
i'm sorry more from overt shipments to
covert shipments but we can do that
again that's in our dna it's what we've
done for for decades um and i think
that's what we'll do
i don't want you to give away any
secrets obviously but what are your
former colleagues doing now and what
would you be doing if you were still on
the job at the cia
what a great question because i think
for a lot of us this this conflict
really has resonated let me just kind of
step back for a moment you know think
about the last 20 years where we've had
you know frankly less than
perfect moral clarity in our wars in
iraq and afghanistan um this is a little
different and so you know this is a kind
of a classic case of david versus
goliath of good versus evil so in some
ways you know i i think a lot of us wish
we were there
um uh what what are my you know old
colleagues doing well first and foremost
let's let's paint the picture that there
has been you know since really 2014 you
know a good you know seven eight years
of established ties between the
ukrainian and the u.s special operations
and let's just say national security
communities let's you know keep it keep
it nebulous with that um so regardless
of whether our our uh our folks both in
the intelligence community and the
special operations community are inside
or not and i don't know um there still
are ties and so there would be certainly
communication um you know that's going
to our to our you know colleagues on the
ukrainian side
provision of intelligence um certainly
as has been reported um you know helping
with kind of logistic shipments weapon
shipments going across but here's a key
piece that i think people are missing
there's been a lot of talk about you
know the the transfer of migs and this
kind of blew up in public i think when
the most important part of the ties
between the ukrainian and uh uh and u.s
national security um
components particularly intelligence
special operations side is the
ukrainians are going to tell us what
they really need not necessarily migs
but what type of equipment do they need
and this can be then passed forward
obviously to the pentagon the white
house
for approval so you know that to me is
the critical part on the ground fighting
what do ukrainians need on a daily basis
that's where we can come in even if
these communications are cross-border
of course the us has incredible
abilities that signals intelligence so
we're listening to what's going on with
the russians and their reports are
actually using commercial cell phones
because their communications are so
messed up so how valuable is all of that
information and intelligence oh my
goodness it's huge i mean you know one
of the things is i think the
the one of the stories of this conflict
will be intelligence collection so first
and foremost it's pretty clear to me and
i don't know but it's pretty clear to me
that that you know western intelligence
obtained the war plans um for uk ukraine
and that was that was critical as we
briefed our foreign partners our nato
allies and got them on board
but as you see the russian kind of
incompetence you know their use of
unencrypted communications is a boon for
us um obviously you know this can be
intercepted much more easily it can be
passed to our ukrainian counterparts
perhaps ukrainians are doing it on their
own as well
um but again it goes to the bigger
picture of of you know kind of the
catastrophic failure of what we thought
was a more powerful you know russian
military machine i think the
intelligence community nailed it in
terms of predicting the invasion frankly
i mean it's clear you know we did so in
in high fat in in fine fashion but i
think there should be you know uh uh you
know and after action later on is i
think we got
wrong um uh you know the assessment on
the on the prowess of the russian
military i mean i think people are
pretty shocked at how poorly they have
performed from using conscripts um to an
inability to kind of coordinate between
you know you know you know air power and
and forces on the ground logistics i
mean even stories of you know expired
mres and and and and russian forces you
know nearly starving
pretty pretty incredible how poorly
they've performed so i think we do have
to look at that down the line
and finally let me ask you many military
analysts are saying the next two weeks
could be pivotal what should we expect
to see
well you know i think again it's there's
there's going to be the russian use of
or you know the russian tactic as we saw
in grozny as we saw in aleppo of
bombarding cities of leveling you know
uh uh you know civilian structures and
we might see a lot of civilian carnage
it's gonna be it's gonna be pretty awful
um you know i think that you know it's
going to be very interesting to see kind
of internally from inside russia you see
reports now that there may be dissension
for example within the fsb the internal
service who it does have a
responsibility for uh for ukraine as
well and so will there be kind of
fractures uh inside russia not not only
amongst you know the people on the
street and we haven't seen all that much
protest but that could change but also
really with that security elite around
putin um you know as as russians
continue to come home in body bags and
there are astounding numbers i mean you
know there are numbers out there that
suggest the russians have lost more uh
uh soldiers than the u.s did in iraq and
afghanistan combined um and so as that
continues you know we have to see kind
of with these fissures inside russia if
they if they you know if if that
increases um and i think that will be
pretty telling they'll put a lot of
pressure on putin mark polymeropoulos
thank you so much for being with us this
evening thanks so
much up next this week's winners and
losers in the media you're watching
brian ross investigates on the long
crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of meteorite and we're joined
now by aide mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of mediaite and aidan
you've chosen as your winner this week
margaret brennan the anchor of the cbs
face the nation program after a tough
interview with the chinese ambassador to
the u.s
why can't you condemn this as an
invasion
well
let's
don't be naive
condemnation
it sounds naive to say that's not an
invasion it doesn't solve the problem
i i would be surprised if russia
will back down by contamination
what is urgently well they back it down
if your president asks vladimir putin to
back down will your president ask
vladimir putin to back we have done so
you know aidan all the right questions
without being strident that's true and i
just want to say that margaret brennan
is perfectly equipped for this kind of
interview she has a background in world
affairs she was a state department
correspondent for cbs news now she's the
anchor of face the nation and not only
does she have that incredible experience
she's also one of the best interrogators
best interviewers on television so when
she had the chance to interrogate the
chinese ambassador to the u.s she really
asked tough questions she asked why the
china which is pretty much allied with
russia would not condemn
this as an invasion because as we know
russia is still calling this kind of
farcically a special military operation
they're declining to call this an
invasion he dodged on that question she
continued to press she also asked him
about alleged genocide of uyghur muslims
in china uh which is something that i
think every chinese official chinese
government official should be asked
about when they uh are interviewed on
american television so asked really
tough questions didn't relent in
following up on them and delivered a
stellar interview and exactly and
doesn't care if he never comes back
because he didn't like the interview for
the loser this week you've chosen once
again candace owens listen to what she
had to say
again going back to my point of people
being stupid or you know trying he's not
trying to commit a genocide of the
ukrainians that obviously makes no sense
because there's there's very there is no
difference ethnically from ukrainians
and russians obviously ukraine wasn't a
thing until 1999 ukraine was created by
the russians it was you know they speak
russian so it's absolutely ridiculous
so candace owens once again uh her
unique take on world events right so
candace owens obviously a conservative
pundit uh she is a host for the daily
wire ben shapiro's uh news outlet
she has since the beginning of the
russian invasion of ukraine presented
pro-putin talking points
now i think that's mainly because she's
a contrarian uh she uh as you can see
there doesn't have a full grasp of
historical events of course ukraine was
a thing before 1989. uh and just because
uh ukraine uh has a certain history
doesn't give russia the right to invade
and conquer it um you know i it reminds
me of a uh of an essay that david french
the conservative writer wrote for the
atlantic where he described candace
owens and others like her like tucker
carlson as textbook contrarians they are
and i have this quote here both
excessively cynical uh about certain
things and excessively credulous of
others so in this case she's
successfully cynical of the ukrainian
case for their invasion by russia and
excessively credulous of what russia
says is their right to invade ukraine
and occupy it though you could have
picked her or a whole group of people
who've taken similar positions that
appear to be very pro-putin pro-russian
right and it's also not only are they
are they anti-whatever the current
common wisdom is in the united states
they're also just far too credulous of
what the russian position is on this uh
now i think no matter what the
historical uh differences are between
ukraine and russia
she's right uh ukrainians uh very a lot
of them speak russian uh the ukrainian
president vladimir
zelinsky speaks better russian than he
speaks ukrainian that doesn't give
russia the the right to invade a
sovereign country and bomb it to
smithereens and in this case uh
president putin has said that the
ukraine
does not or should not exist and they
seem to be picking up on that line all
right aidan mclaughlin editor-in-chief
of media thank you so much for being
with us this week for the winners and
losers and thanks to all of you for
watching we'll be back again here next
week on the long crime trial network
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
do
you